so morgan wallin is apologizing for
using the n-word
on a drunken night out in nashville now
tmz has the exclusive video so he can't
show it to you
but i've watched i'm sure many of you
have watched it he absolutely says it
there's no denying that
once the video hit the internet last
night morgan had this to say to
e.t i'm embarrassed and sorry i used an
unacceptable and inappropriate racial
slur that i wish i could take back
there are no excuses to use this type of
language ever i want to sincerely
apologize
for using the word i promise to do
better
uh yeah but some female country artists
are saying that that apology
isn't enough mickey guyton tweeted this
is not his first time using
that unacceptable racial slur quote
unquote and we all
know that so what exactly are y'all
gonna do about it
crickets won't work this time how many
passes will you continue to give
asking for a friend no one deserves to
be canceled but this
is unacceptable promise to do better
don't
mean crap and mary moore said it
actually is representative of our town
because this isn't his first scuffle
and he just demolished a huge streaming
record last month regardless we all know
it wasn't his first time using that word
we keep them rich and protected at all
costs
with no recourse
yeah and uh kelsey ballerini uh
retweeted an option that said a female
artist
would have been dropped by her label if
she had done five
percent of the stuff that morgan has
done kelsey added the truth is the truth
if you remember it was in october that
morgan was booted from saturday night
live
uh for not following covet protocols
before his appearance
but he was rebooked less than two months
later
yeah so the fault for morgan using the
racial slurs playing out right now so
about an hour ago
i heart media is dropping morgan from
the radio stations that's about
850 radio stations across the country
about 45 minutes ago intercom radio
station dropped him
that's 235 stations about 30 minutes ago
cmt announced they are dropping his
content
so so the country community is
definitely having something to say about
this
just about 15 minutes ago his record
contract
has been suspended indefinitely so the
fallout is
for morgan like this is a guy that i'm
pretty sure his album has been number
one in the billboard for the last three
weeks or it was number one
for several weeks so there is followed
i'm shocked
at how fast this is happening for morgan
wallin what do you think uh
i know i'm just telling you all this
right now dwayne that's what you think
of
that yeah there's so much to process
there first off i really like what
mickey
guyton says because being a black female
country singer is very powerful in
canada we have sasha smashing records
and i think it's great
that we're seeing things like that and
one thing i read about her because i was
reading tmz this morning
is a lot of the country music community
will say this isn't us
but she said no this is you this is us
and it's such a big thing that in 2021
we're still dealing with it
like i'm somebody who goes out to
schools and one thing that's happening
and parents are asking me about is that
their black kid is being asked by white
kids if they can get an n pass and so
this is not an isolated incident
this is something that is going on in
society in 2021
that people think it's acceptable to
just use this word and toss it around
and i don't believe in cancel culture
because i don't think it corrects the
problem
so i think when you're hearing him just
kick it with his friends and say
this word it's something that his all of
his friends
in his culture and his community and it
goes beyond just country music
and so i don't think the right way is to
just reprimand but i think we have to
have a bigger discussion of what that
word means
unfortunately still in 2021
yeah yeah and i i know i woke up first
thing this morning the first headline i
saw was that cumulus radio which is they
were primarily country
radio network it was 400 station that he
got dropped from and this was last night
after it uh after it hit tmz and so you
know the numbers are the numbers are
staggering
and i know that everybody is you know
looking now towards these streaming
services and management can do people
have contracts with them
can sort of do what they want and we
know what radio's reaction is but i know
people are looking now towards streaming
services
and i think that for streaming services
it may be a bit more complicated
uh for them but uh they're gonna have to
do something because and i don't know
whether
you can treat this as an isolated
incident and or or you then have to
start going
and looking at the the histories of all
the other artists that you stream
because there's some really terrible
people
who you can listen to their music
whenever you want to and that again is
of course
the much larger conversation that people
have been having you know for the past
hundred years whether you
separate the artists from the art but um
but no i think that what what was said
earlier in that is this can't be
a i'll do better um you know i've heard
now more apologies from
uh from morgan wallin then i have songs
from morgan wallin
and this is two in the last couple of
months and
you know the i will do better is just
not going to cut it and i think that
you know they did the right thing and
then you know and and the action that
was taken
is you know 100 percent not just
protecting your own assets i don't think
that this is about money i think that
this is people
realizing that they absolutely want to
distance themselves from somebody where
they know that this was not the first
time you said it
yeah tons of comments so yep he's done
done moss is bi
he's done tony says you're just trying
not to get cancelled
um yeah neil says it shouldn't be on his
mind
it will pop out again stern says
everyone needs a victim this is
cancelled culture
at its finest a voice is using the word
during black history month is beyond me
um yeah jose's lies they're not
cancelling i'm shocked with the record
label thing though like radio stations
is one
because that's the thing i mean these
days radio isn't as powerful as it once
was like you said what russ
with all the streaming services but for
his record label to step in when he has
the number one album like it's funny i
mentioned when we're talking about
marilyn manson yesterday
and his record label dropped him i
thought not his biggest deal because
marilyn manson's not hitting number one
in the charts anymore but for morgan
walden this guy
has been absolutely huge with this album
over the past month for his record label
to say no no we're you know suspending
his contract right now like that's crazy
yeah i think that you also have to look
at and i don't have these details but
what i'd be curious to know is
who else is on that label and how many
of them called right
right yeah yeah absolutely yeah